[Music]
it's that time of the year when LA's
pretty narcissist use their awards to
take shots at diseased ugly narcissus as
these nine films compete for Hollywood's
highest honor because back when it was
just by the Academy couldn't trick you
in the rooting for something actually
saw this year's honest nominees for Best
Picture are from Denis Villeneuve a
comes Amy Adams second movie this year
about trying to relate to an alien no
one gets along with they will have
audiences trying to wrap their mind
around what they just saw because
they're pretty sure the part about the
Chinese guy makes absolutely no sense
with words from first-time director
Garth Davis comes the film about the kid
who goes to India with Nicole Kidman I
think and finds a lion or something he
all right it's the one with Deb Patel I
hear it's really good but honestly I've
only seen the trailer now you've got to
stop releasing all the oscar movies at
the same time if you say you've seen
this you're probably lying return to
West Texas for that one grizzled cowboy
voice Jeff Bridges guys your good friend
is your fool morning this I know Cunha
we suspect it might be good for a film
that's so entertaining straightforward
and unpretentious it has no chance of
actually winning Best Picture hell it's
a high honor just to be nominated
witness the incredible untold story of
the hidden contributions black women
make of the space program whose
brilliance was no match with a stubborn
prejudice of the times but don't worry
it won't make white people feel too bad
about themselves see Kevin Costner is
one of the good ones Diary of a black
mad woman from the writer of the
Adventures of Rocky and Bullwinkle wait
really comes the exact opposite of that
it's sort of gonna knock your block off
as you take a non-stop Greek raid to set
bill let by a hard-drinking
irritable Boston man living in the
shadow it was more successful older
brother gee wonder how Casey Affleck
managed to get into character
man chested by the [ __ ] sea follow
along on the poetic unfolding of the
life beautifully directed by Barry
Jenkins as this young black gay man
struggles to escape from poverty and
drug addiction told across three decades
based on a play based on the life story
of its author so yeah I'd say it's
nominated for an Oscar all of the Oscar
things watch what's clearly a stage play
Denzel Washington decided to film
because aside from the garbage truck at
the beginning they're just talking in a
house the entire time as these actors
bravely explore how much acting you can
fit into one movie featuring Wow that
dig you best be making sure they're
doing right by you
nuance that day seventeen years ago that
boy wasn't gonna get involved in those
fault and it's not acting don't is the
guy who won another thing doesn't think
I had dreams at Hope
what about highlights what about me
actors enjoy the brief window of time
before Mel Gibson burns his bridge to
Hollywood again as he follows up the
Jesus movie he filled with blood and
gore with another story about a
historical pacifist filled with tons of
blood and gore
was that necessary oh I think I'm gonna
puke war and pieces experience that
gorgeous ode to the musicals of cinemas
past that earn nominations for Best
Picture Best Actor Best Actress Best
Director nice Best Cinematography sure
this screenplay really best song
okay I get that one best sound mixing
fine
best song again cause if nobody watched
sing Street best costume design with the
pen they're just wearing clothes man the
Academy just can't resist a movie about
how special the movies are can a
Hollywood [ __ ] those are your
nominees for Best Picture and since we
bet there will be a million speeches
about Trump at the Oscars we thought
we'd get an equal time to respond via
Twitter in our starring section starring
the highly overrated Meryl Streep
mar-a-lago Holly bad hombres potential
terrorists immigrants a six at best
seven eight now that's a real American
thank you for your service in the
Braveheart war that spider-man I know
that one we're both from Queens
smart kid Oh Jay Simpson great guy great
golfers I'll turn it in fact sad sad sad
sad sad the Oscars 2017 thanks for
stopping by mr. president fake views you
have fake views more like not honest
trailers low-energy Wow Amy Adams got
snubbed this year and she's over five
when she is nominated
what's an actor gotta do to finally win
an Oscar ah all right
never mind hey screen junkies want to
watch the Oscars with us then tune in
this Sunday to our Oscar watch party
live on YouTube on our screen junkies
News Channel watch along with your
favorite screen junkies personalities
starting at 5:00 p.m. Pacific time this
Sunday night as we give our honest take
on this year's ceremony
I wonder if la-la-land will win anything
hot-diggity-dog I was a dual Bay burger
with cheese muhfucka hi I'm magical
princess from another dimension
purple liam neeson punches puppies I am
veggies I am the knight I am well man